what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with the events of
Justice League no justice again this is
kind of cool here and and and I really
like what Snyder's doing it's one of
these really interesting ideas right I
mean like like Galactus meets the
Celestials it's kind of cool and and
really like for those of you guys who
have read Marvel Comics for a long time
ah the Omega Titans really are a lot
more like the Celestials are really more
of a great blend of the Celestials
rather and and Galactus than anything
else because the idea of the story up to
this point has basically been that like
Brainiac showed up on earth and
basically gathered the most prominent
superheroes on earth basically the Teen
Titans the magic wielders and the
Justice League and then split them up
into separate teams and then in turn
took them to the planet colu
and basically said when you broke the
source wall oh you [ __ ] the Omega
Titans now the cool thing about that
that's one of the great things about
this whole thing is that for the guys
who were new anyway when it comes to
come above publishers you have what are
called soft reboots then you have hard
reboots you have relaunches like what
Marvel does which is basically calling
it a reboot but it's not really and then
you have what it was kind of like an
event that will shuffle things around
and that's really what this is this is
an event that shuffles things around and
the idea is that with the source wall
having been cracked in the aftermath of
dark nights metal it is it's almost like
the circumstance whereby everyone who is
trapped in the source wall was released
now of course DC has kind of removed
that from continuity and we know that
because the source walls still there and
everybody who was in the source wall
seems to you know seems to still be
trapped so I think that's kind of been
removed and that's really not something
that happens anymore
I really didn't happen at all but the
fact remains with a source wall crock it
means that things can come from outside
of the main DC universe or the main DC
multiverse but it would also allow for
for DC to kind of pick and choose what
gets released from the source wall for
example we may see a story in the future
where we see the return of imperiex who
was actually a really interesting
villain in the late 1990s uh it was
about as close as DC ever actually got
to Galactus in the sense that like
imperiex when when the Justice League
first encountered Imperials
they faced off against it only to
realize that it was basically a drone
and the actual imperiex was insanely
powerful was far more powerful than that
drone was so there's really cool
elements of course you kakan the father
of Darkseid is someone that we will
probably see emerge from the source wall
are from Hal Jordan in the Green Lantern
Corps we saw that in that story but
there's cool little things that go on
the other part of this is that in the
last video we had talked about how the
planet colu basically had this this kind
of like all these different worlds did
it basically being confined and that was
a hallmark of Brainiac ever since
Brainiac really showed up in the early
days of DC and even going forward in
terms of flushing his character out his
main MO was basically traveling around
the the universe and then like capturing
worlds or cities and then bottling them
hence the the the concept of the bottled
city of Kandor but what this does is it
basically allows DC to kind of come
along and say well these various worlds
that you thought were destroyed were
never actually destroyed instead they
were just captured and bottled by
Brainiac and they were left here on colu
and has just been that way ever since
the idea is that with all these worlds
basically being discovered there's still
life on these worlds and so in response
you basically have like the telepath
Martian Manhunter star up who are really
like hearing from all the voices in this
world and the idea is to essentially
make these trees grow right like you
know the tree of entropy and wisdom and
mystery and and you know all I kind of
good stuff but the idea is that in any
one particular world these are mega
Titans it kind of like planted seeds so
to speak you know because this seed
exists whatever aspect of these four
concepts the planet grows towards that
in turn will summon that that Omega
Titan so for example on colu it's really
all about like wisdom it's about like
experience knowledge things like that
and so because it's about wisdom that
tree has the most energy a really it's
the only tree this alive and it summons
the the wisdom Omega Titan with this in
mind after basically coming across
Brainiac 2.0 where the super heroes of
Earth are kind of continuing on this
campaign and say hey look like we can
save the planet
ultimately the responsibly niak 2.0 is
no you can't and the reason why is
because all of this is predicated on the
nature of Brainiac where Brainiac is a
villain that has historically always had
nefarious tendencies where there have
been events like convergence things like
that where brainiacs kind of been
reworked and reshuffled and been changed
around and different things like that
and we're like various stories over the
course of DC's publication history have
given us other you know future
iterations of Rainey ack the fact
remains here that as most fans know him
he's a villain he's a main villain of
Superman and a main villain of Earth the
argument of Brainiac 2.0 is nothing is
what you think it is
your idea was Brainiac brought you here
under the auspices that each of you had
some component where they split you into
teams because those of you in those
teams possess a level of power that
would allow to sort of rebalance
everything to restore life to all the
trees and in turn send the Omega Titan
away but the responsive rainier 2.0 is
that's not true the whole reason why
here is because this is the one planet
Brainiac was never able to conquer and
so because that his goal is to basically
take over the world like take over this
planet the idea was to use you guys to
restore balance quote-unquote to the
four trees the Omega Titans would leave
and they would immediately travel to
earth and because all the superheroes
for the most part reside on earth - the
Green Lantern Corps all that would be
left would be the Lantern Corps that
would be in and so with there being like
no more Superman no more Wonder Woman
Batman or any of that stuff then like
the universe would be ripe for the
picking basically you were brought here
to set the stage for Brainiac to conquer
the universe and it's kind of
interesting because the response of
Beast Boy is like no that's not true and
you're lying we have to believe that
this world can be saved so it's really
you know hopeful idealism in the face of
what is really nothing more than
impending death and so it's kind of cool
because from here you basically switch
over to team Wonder you pick up with
with Wonder Woman and Etrigan as well as
Raven and in dr. fate and then of course
that's Hana and this is kind of
interesting because Wonder Woman really
kind of takes the reins here and Wonder
Woman's idea is I've been blessed with
magic by the gods and it's interesting
that Snyder blends these two things
because we're arrogant and these guys
are kind of like look she's not really a
magic wielder she has magic in so far
that like godly beings granted her
powers she's not a tried and true magic
wielder but the responsive Wonder Woman
is well I can pull this off Wonder Woman
uses her lasso of truth which basically
imbues the tree with magic of sorts and
in turn like awakens the tree and this
is kind of intriguing because if I'm
being honest here I feel like it's kind
of Snyder's way of saying like I really
like Wonder Woman so I wanted to be able
to use magic which is not a bad thing I
mean I would say up until recent years
with the exception of stories like Higa
taya Wonder Woman never really seem to
get her do she was just a chick who was
there this is Scott Snyder grabbing the
Wonder Woman mythos and saying she's not
just a chick who got some magical tools
from the gods that they really are
imbued with magic and she really is part
of that magic community whether we
really want to acknowledge that or not
so again if Snyder's take on things and
it works exceedingly well from here we
jump to cyborg and this is kind of cool
because from my perspective
cyborgs never really been a character
who's been interesting to me I would
never sit down of my own volition and
read the cyborg solo series because Sabo
was never interesting to me with the
character of cyberwar he gets again kind
of a cool moment and this really seems
to what Snyder's going on really spiders
doing here is just taking a break away
from what we're used to because when you
sit down and you read almost anything
from DC Comics it usually kind of boils
down to like
Batman or Superman saving the day but
it's cool to remove things from that
it's cool do to basically walk away from
the idea that Batman and Superman are
gonna save the day and in fact in this
story make them wonder what a really
amount to like background characters and
focus on like the lesser respected guys
and kind of beef up their popularity and
the way this happens with cyborg is that
because of the fact that this is a treat
that basically deals with like you know
artificial intelligence and and so on
and so forth what he ends up doing is
using his mother box to sink into the
treat and then start you know basically
tapping into its artificial intelligence
and it's cool because it makes him like
an interesting character it makes me
useful for the most part and so of
course basically reawakening the streak
the idea here is a slider also hits on
the arm on the notion that they were
like these apples ago the first seed
that grew on this planet came in like
this was the first tree that basically
popped up but as the planet began to
cater itself towards wisdom this tree
basically died and the wisdom tree grew
but for for a reason that's not really
explained here there's significance to
this the seed of source you know to this
apple of Eden so to speak and so as a
result side where doesn't really know
what to make of it but he does know it's
important and so this is when things
really begin to sort of pop off and they
really begin to boil down because what
happens here is we should basically
switch over to team mystery - Superman -
Sinestro Starfire and - uh you know
Starro himself as well as well as
Martian Manhunter and to be honest Scott
Snyder if you ever happen to see this
video this team is so stacked and I
don't understand why he would stack this
team so bad this is a pretty Opie team
but the biggest issue they have here is
that again they're kind of tapping into
the mind of these guys and they haven't
quite figured out how to active or at
least they have figured it out but they
haven't activated their tree yet the
other half of this is that these worlds
really amount to hostages they don't
really know what's gonna happen they
know that if the Omega Titan consumes
the world all these worlds will die in
all these little mini mini plans will be
destroyed in the process and so this is
one of those things were it's like the
moral compass of the superhero community
kind of bumps up against what needs to
be done but the cool thing about this is
it's Snyder could use this to basically
bring back long-lost concepts in DC
Comics but we also end up basically
finding out of the tamarind the
homeworld of Starfire is locked here and
so it's essentially a way to like bring
back the entirety of her people there's
all these cool things that go on all
these cool little themes these little
goodies if Snyder throws into the story
that allows us to see the return of
things and so ultimately the response of
really Superman and his guys are okay
Sinestro create a
truck that will get all these worlds off
planet and while you're doing that will
buy you time and so essentially everyone
is recalled and in turn they all start
jumping into the fray for the purpose of
just serving as a distraction in order
to essentially take out this Omega Titan
now the heroes know they can't destroy
it right I mean you're talking about an
astronomical amount of power and DC
plays it fast and loose when they're
talking about like universal scale
characters you don't really see
characters on a universal level in the
same capacity that you see in Marvel
right like the universal landscape of DC
is very much undeveloped like there's a
lot there that we don't know
I think there's ample room to kind of
build that up but DC does fine with what
they have I mean you know at the end of
the day and it all works I mean they're
one of the biggest common book companies
in the world they must be doing
something right and so is so there's
like there's there's a lot of cool stuff
that you can do with that but the whole
point here is that the various members
of the superhero community do what they
can the Justice League the Teen Titans
more or less they all kind of do what
they can but at the end of the day
they're not really designed to win
they're really designed it just kind of
be a stopgap measure that's it and so
where star is a CEO is it basically
destroyed in the process this leads to
like the Omega Titan consuming the
entirety of the world and that's it and
so Cola basically explodes in its
entirety and it's not really known which
members of the Justice League survive
and so picking back up with Green Arrow
and Amanda Waller who have really been
in a standoff you know regarding this
seed on earth and whether or not they
should destroy it whether or not they
should activate it in the middle of all
this the seeds suddenly kicks off which
is exactly what we were told what
happened when colou was destroyed and
that planet was consumed the new seed
immediately starts sprouting trees and
this is cool this is a great idea by
Scott Snyder because what it means is we
can admit we can basically immediately
hop from one action-packed event to
another there's no real phase where it's
like okay well the planet was destroyed
and we've got three weeks until the
trees grow like they immediately pop up
like they're right there and so right
off the bat the earth is in danger and
the reason why is because instead of
like the Omega Titans making their way
to earth
gradually getting there instead like
they're immediately there and so they
actually get there before the Justice
League does depending on which room
registered members of the league survive
so this is cool and it's a really
awesome idea because Oliver Queen kind
of plays the role of the fan he plays
the role of us as the reader as know the
Justice League will be here it's only a
matter of time they'll be here and
they'll save us but the responsive
Amanda Waller is they probably won't
here's the question you have to ask
if all these worlds were saved by
Sinestro what resources will they end up
bringing because Oliver Queen's response
was to basically send an SOS to the
Green Lantern Corps and while the Green
Lantern Corps would be cool we don't
really know if the Green Lantern Corps
would stand much of a chance against
these Omega Titans if they even respond
at all and if they don't get the message
in time then the Justice League with
whatever reinforcements show up my hope
does superboy-prime
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comment explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the robb cork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]